not all heroes wear capes some even
carry hammers workers at an Oakland
pizza shop fending off a fourth robbery
attempt in just over a month and they
only had a hammer to fight back they
also threw a recycling bin at the crook
the suspect was later arrested it's just
the latest shocking video to come out of
crimer ravaged Oakland which is getting
so bad that Governor Gavin Nome is being
forced to take action he will be
deploying 120 more California Highway
Patrol officers in Oakland to have it's
an effort to crack down on crime it only
took some major businesses to flee like
that In-N-Out Burger shutting down as
well as big companies like blue shield
and Clorox warning employees to hire
security or take other actions to keep
workers safe but is the governor only
taking this action to save his favorite
burger joint so I come into your state
yes sir first thing I love to do I go
straight to In-N-Out burer that is one
of the greatest things of your state
legit you're right about in and out of
burger and that's a great way to end he
said Greg that he wants to send the
highway patrol to restore a sense of
safety what about actual safety no it's
appearances only matter I mean just look
at him look at him somebody here on this
table called this first that to get any
action done you may have to get the
politician to feel the pain of their own
policies intimately and he got it right
in the gut because I predicted Inn out
was going to be the Catalyst because
it's his family's favorite restaurant
and when in andout closed that was a
direct shot at him because you could BS
the public but you can't BS your kids
who are now wishing he had gotten
recalled because they could have their
burger the intensity of pain that a
public endures is based on the time that
it takes the Democrats to start acting
like Republicans and so the goal for
this for us is to speed that up get the
party of Ruin to come to their senses
because because the Democratic party for
some reason lately is addicted to chaos
and we have to keep doing these
interventions right and like an addict
the left has to hit rock bottom the
problem is they're taking everybody with
them well you know I'm happy for there
to be more Highway Patrol but judge if
they don't change the prosecu the
prosecution record then you know he
could get behind that repeal effort that
I've mentioned to repeal Prop 47 it has
300,000 signatures the governor could
put some fire into that instead of just
having to hire the officers yes he could
do that and but but I just want to go
back to the beginning of this with Gavin
Newsome it's always about him you
remember was it last week or the week
before with Target and he wanted the
manager called immediately when she said
this is all Gavin Newsome's fault
describing all the theft that was going
on um and now he sends 120 uh uh
California Highway Patrol and and at
first I thought that was strange then I
found found out with a little research
that the state police apparently have
merged with highway patrol in California
which is you know why they're involved
in this but as violent crime is going
down in some areas not down
significantly I mean Oakland is through
the roof and you've got you've got it to
the point where it's a third world
country where companies are telling
people don't go out to get lunch don't
eat lunch Clorox and Kaiser permanent
that are saying when you get here we'll
call security we'll walk out with you
this is the United States of America and
this guy thinks he should be a candidate
for president I mean this is absurd and
that they don't take the appropriate
action Don uh that that you talk about
uh Dana with respect to law enforcement
and bail and police making arrests then
they're going to they're going to live
with this this is his signature State
and they defunded police in 2021 they
also made a decision to get rid of all
of these violence prevention programs
where kids had opportunities to get
involved in after school programs not
get involved in gangs you that's all at
his feet and tosey I always feel I know
all of us do but I immediately think
about the worker who's getting an hourly
wage and they are not protected and
they're trying to protect themselves
with a hammer yeah exactly and they know
firsthand that people like Gavin Newsome
and Joe Biden and his administration
they don't actually care about the pain
and the struggles and hardship that
people in these communities are going
through just trying to survive and get
to work and home safely at the end of
the day so the the the realization is
not like oh my gosh crime is actually
really bad let's do something about it
the pain is coming from the threat to
their power they're seeing that the
American people are very concerned about
rampant crime in their communities
they're very concerned about the the
open borders in the immigration crisis
and are recognizing this is actually
going to have a big impact in the
outcome of this election it's an
election year Gavin Nome Joe Biden all
these other people in cities that have
not cared about this stuff until now are
are realizing okay well this is going to
drive voters let's make pretend like we
care start doing something about it and
hope that the American people are stupid
enough to fall for it they think very
little of us we're not stupid and we're
paying attention I mean so somebody like
a company like Inn Out Burger can really
get headlines right but what about small
businesses like I don't ever hear the
administration or gavu and they don't
talk about small businesses very often
yeah they should if I was advising them
I would talk small business a lot but
I'm not because I have a real job Dana
we're making Newsome president just like
MSNBC made Trump president in 2016 all
of these positive stories about Gavin
deploying anti-me task forces all over
California it's happening Dana I can
feel it the guy are you off the Michelle
Obama train now oh no we're going to
cover that heavily tonight I'm sure you
are this guy went so far left during Co
he's now doing a massive course
correction and he's going on Fox he's
admitting homelessness is a problem he's
going to Battleground state he's
deploying the police all you need to be
president height hair and a lot of money
guy's got it all if he can just run a
normal campaign he's a shoe in for 28
you say listen I was the first guy to
marry Gaye but I don't think
kindergarteners should read about gay
sex I'm going to fight Street crime but
I'm also going to fight white collar
crime I want to secure the Border I also
want immigration I want to wean people
off of welfare and then wean
corporations off welf Fair too it's a
layup if I was advising him that's what
I'd tell him I'll probably lose my job
tomorrow and I'll be
available we don't want that a joke we
don't want to lose you but if you cover
that story one more time tonight you're
gonna you're explosions in my head do
you know why they call it In-N-Out why
just think about it D come on I still
don't get it okay hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else